[Music]
America's Middle Eastern Wars have cost
trillions and produced no benefit for
the United States but as candidate Trump
like to point out on the stump they
never end
on Sunday the u.s. carried out
airstrikes against an Iraqi militia
group tied to Iran the strikes came
after a u.s. civilian contractor was
killed in a rocket attack the Iraqi
government has objected the Iranians
have responded could this be a step
toward the war with Iran that so many of
Washington's foreign policy
establishment are hot for Doug McGregor
is a retired US Army colonel and author
of the book margin of victory and he
joins us now colonel I'm I'm enough of a
19th century imperialist
to take Lord Palmerston that a great
power can't have its citizens killed
with immunity impunity and expect to
remain great but what is the broader
strategic objective in this current
military action well good evening mark
Palmerston was a smart man he also said
that Gladstone would end his political
career in a madhouse he wasn't far from
Rana
I think if Americans look at this the
first question is what are we doing in
Syria in Iraq with troops on the ground
what's the purpose to begin with I don't
think that's ever been fully explained
what we've heard routinely is that we're
coming out we're coming out we're coming
out each time the president seems to be
subverted and we end up with a few more
troops left I think that's what's
happened here and it may help explain
what was done on Sunday this contractor
was killed in this rocket attack in the
vicinity of a place called kheer cook
right now if you look at the five
targets three inside Iraq and two in
Syria these targets are 250 miles 300
miles away from Kirkuk hmm so we're not
striking anything in the vicinity of
where this event happened secondly all
of these targets
yes they're part of what we call the PMF
the popular mobilized force they are
Iranian trained they are Shiite militias
and they have been killing Isis right
and al-nusrah and al-qaida right and
they have actually liberated and
protected Christians from our friends in
Isis now Isis is largely gone but
they're still digging them out in lower
Syria for some reason we chose to strike
all of these targets instead of looking
for something in the vicinity of Kirkuk
so it seems that your essential
suspicion is probably accurate well this
looks like an attempt to drag us into
something well let me let me just ask
you about that because you you basically
said that these guys were fighting Isis
the last time any of us took any
attention of them so they were the enemy
of our enemy but it turns out that
they're now also our enemy do we have a
are we just tourists in the heart of
darkness staggering staggering around
from one barely understood faction to
another well I think staggering around
from one misunderstood faction to the
next is a damn good description I don't
think we have any idea what we're doing
there and I think the president has been
skillfully misinformed I think he's
being walked into another ambush much as
he was last summer when all of a sudden
he was presented with his fait accompli
they've shot down a global hawk we have
to attack Iran now we have attacked
these Iranian backed forces the Iraqi
government I think is going to try and
throw us out the Parliament has already
voted unanimously for us to leave so I
think the next step is for the Iraqis to
say get out I don't think that the
Iranians or the Iraqis per se are
necessarily going to respond in the way
the neo cons would hope well well
president Trump has always said he's
thought these wars were a complete waste
of time they've gone on now for a
generation but the ineffectually but the
question the question is is he has he
become the captive of the the bush-era
foreign policy men
wandered in and out of this
administration just quickly well if he's
not the captive he certainly looks like
it and he is now the only thing standing
between us and another pointless war
he's the one who can say no and he does
but he needs to understand that's not
enough he's got to move the people
around him who are part of the problem
out thanks thank you for that Connell